ladies and gentlemen my April Fool's
joke was an overwhelming success and
also backfired very very badly on
Saturday April 1st I put out a video
called I'm leaving YouTube The Mob one
the show is over that video as of this
recording has more than half a million
views
overwhelmingly people understood that
it's a joke and part of the reason you
could tell it was a joke is in the video
I say that the right wing mob took
everything that our toilets aren't even
flushing at the studio and that I'm
having to flush 10 to 15 times now
that's a reference to Trump's obsession
with toilets the entire thing was a joke
but one of the things that is a re this
is sort of a math thing okay and I I
realize this
if 500 000 people see the video
and 99.9 realize it's a joke
if 0.1 percent don't realize it's a joke
that's still 500 people who think I'm
being serious and of those 500 people
half might email me now I think in
reality the numbers are more like
99.5 of the audience realized it was a
joke but about half of one percent
didn't
when these are the numbers that's
thousands of people
and I received hundreds of emails saying
David I'm so sorry
that this is happening I can't believe
it uh Brian Tyler Cohen fellow YouTuber
texted me and said hey people are
contacting me saying you've got to help
David packman he needs help they're
taking his show can you get him a lawyer
can you help him
um I heard from actors and politicians
that I didn't even know had any idea who
I was saying David I'm really upset can
I can I get you an agent can I get you
how can I help you get the show back and
I explained to everybody it's just an
April Fool's joke but it is really
something else a couple of the messages
that I got
um here is one this this I really found
this one funny Jill commented my husband
called out to me while I was in another
room Pac-Man is ending the show The
anti-woke Mob one and I called back
today is April 1st
I love this I I'm visualizing Jill's
husband yelling from the other room and
Jill immediately knows what's going on
and says it's April 1st and then Jill's
husband goes oh and then goes right back
to it but Jill did say I would have
believed it if I saw the video first I
got a bunch of different voicemails
about this here's one
hello David please stick with it don't
let them son of a put you out of
business you're stronger than they are
I don't think they got God on their side
when it gets down to it just keep up the
good fight and help us out yep well
listen we're okay we're okay I did get a
second voice I actually got hundreds of
voicemails about this I just picked two
I'm from Minnesota I just want to tell
you that we're with you man we're this
is awful what's happening and I'd like
to see you get back on anyway if there's
anything I can do to help let us let us
know
so listen
um
I appreciate the outpouring of support
after the right wing mob did come after
me we are not canceled in fact March on
YouTube was one of our best months in a
long time thanks to the right wing mob
they generated such interest in what we
are doing and of course the bad faith
takes about what we did led to a
backlash where we actually uh I I'm so
grateful to everybody is the point
um one other aspect to this which I have
to say has been so uplifting some people
wrote to me and said David you know I
realized it was an April Fool's joke by
the end of the video but in the first 40
50 seconds I thought it was for real and
I was so upset that it made me realize
how much I value what you do I was
taking it for granted and then when you
said that they won that they canceled
you I became so upset that I realized I
really should actually be supporting the
show if I was this upset at the prospect
of the show being canceled it made me
realize I actually really value this and
I should I should get a membership for a
couple of bucks and a couple dozen
people wrote to me about that so listen
if you were upset by the joke it's just
a joke okay that's all it is the show is
here we had a fantastic March we are
here we've got so much going on we're
pushing into the primaries the Trump
indictment the arraignment all of it the
2024 election and I appreciate every
single person in the audience including
everybody who has started new Support
over the last week let's keep going
let's press forward